you have made me laugh harder than
anybody has made me laugh and that's my
favorite stuff you know my favorite and
I've told you this before my favorite
movie of all time I don't think I go two
weeks without mentioning it is Windy
City Heat yeah that was uh that was my
favorite I think that was my favorite
project ever also ever yeah it was uh
that was a lot of fun to do for the few
people listening that maybe don't know
what it is how did first of all I think
that was a guy that was on your radio
show he was like no I'm not well no
there's um there are two of my friends
guy named Don Barris and Tony Barbieri
Don Barris is my warm-up guy Tony's been
a writer on our show and on the man show
for 20 plus years I met these guys
through our mutual friend Daniel
kellison okay he was friendly with Tony
Barbieri they came to a dinner at my
house one night this is years ago I was
a disc jockey I was a Morning Show yeah
with Kevin and Bean at K-Rock and uh
they came to my house and they they
brought some cassette tapes they had
been taping these calls with this comic
named Perry caravello he's a comic well
yeah and that's where they met at the
comedy store they've been taping these
phone calls and playing all these crazy
characters and pulling these ridiculous
pranks on this guy and I do remember my
ex-wife at the time we were listening to
the tapes I remember her looking at me
and she goes oh no
she knew that this is the beginning of
something for me and so then I got
involved in it and it's just crazy it's
like it's there are many there are like
a hundred people pranking one guy I mean
that's really what this this is about
and this guy Perry we made a movie and
we convinced him he was going to be a
big action star of a movie he played his
character Stone Fury and the whole thing
was just just to goof on him oh you have
no idea you just have to Google Windy
City Heat what's your favorite scene
from Windy City Heat well
um well I'll tell you it's interesting
how that movie how it got made in the
first place I begged Comedy Central
because they didn't understand what we
were talking about and I said just give
me twenty five thousand dollars and I'll
shoot the first scene and so the first
scene is Perry auditioning for this role
and just one thing happens after another
we're just just annoying him threatening
he screams and yells and he's a lunatic
and um I played it for we edited it and
we played it for the head of Comedy
Central and I'm never still to this day
never seen anyone laugh harder than this
guy Phil Heller did he was rolling on
the ground laughing he was dying
laughing everything I see from that
movie I die nothing makes me laugh over
and over and over again more than that
movie and it's every scene of that movie
okay my favorite scene is the red bat
blue bat scene
um well you know what pull it up red bat
blue bat Windy City Heat Perry is
sitting in a chair and he's restrained
he's been tied up by the the two
villains Big Lou and and these two
characters played by Tony well he thinks
he's in that for those that don't know
he thinks he's in a movie so the Perry
character
it's hard if you're just listening to
this but the Perry character he's an
actor he believes he got this movie and
this is the red bat blue bat scene yeah
okay in which Perry is uh okay so now
Bobcat Goldthwait is the director he
comes in he goes all right mole and mole
is characters high all the time he
doesn't listen he's he's real he's the
goofball he says mole
this is a red bat and a blue bat the red
bat is a real bat do not hit him with
the real bat no if the blue bat was the
robot red bat is the fake bat this is
the bat that won't hurt him he's gonna
hit him in the head with the bat the
blue bat
do not use the blue bat
is this great Moment of clarity where of
course mole picks up the wrong bat is
about to bash Harry in the head with it
where Perry goes why is the blue bat
even there
it's actually a really good question so
when you sit there and you're writing
when we find it we'll put it up okay
there it is no no more stunt doubles
when it comes to the rest of this movie
because I'm looking at me as another
Jackie Chan I'm gonna do all stunts I
want to explain this again red bat is
the wooden bed don't hit Perry don't hit
the money so blue bat rubber rubber back
guys
let's go all right here we go
and that ain't great didn't even give me
a truly him
[Music]
oh Jesus [ __ ] price it's a [ __ ] you
wouldn't bet you [ __ ] how much
preparation goes into like that scene
where we sat down and and and hashed out
the three of us Tony Don and me and I
remember just sitting there typing it
all up and we just imagined what Perry
would do and with one exception he did
every single thing we thought he was
going to do there was only one exception
in the movie like he reacted we knew him
so well at that point that he it was
almost as if it was scripted even though
it wasn't because we knew what he was
how he was going to react the one thing
that was a little bit different there
was a scene he had this beautiful
co-star and
um he was going to make love to her and
they were going to be naked together it
was like a nude scene
in which case in the previous scene he
had demanded a stunt double because we
threw him into a dumpster full of like
cow [ __ ] over and over again and they
said Perry why don't you get a stunt
double he's like I want a stunt double
and so then the next scene is the
lovemaking scene and just as Perry's
about to make love we bring in the
double
now we thought Perry was going to lose
his mind and get really mad about this
but
um in real reality we didn't realize he
was lactose intolerant and we'd forced
him to drink this big like shake that
had milk in it and he had to go to the
bathroom so badly that he didn't want to
be in the love
and there I mean it's uh it's hard to
explain but all I can say and the most
important thing to know going into it is
that it is 100 real like none of it is
cooked it is absolutely real there's not
one moment in that movie that um that we
faked to make the movie funnier and why
is it real why is it underground like
Why didn't it explode onto this it was
the lowest rated movie Comedy Central
had ever put on their Network
why is that it's the funniest thing I've
ever in my life aired once and never
again why
um because no one wanted us because
people didn't know what it was there
were no
um known stars in it it was hard to
follow there's no setup you really need
like you really need some friend to tell
you about it before you watch it do you
think that people didn't believe that it
was actually real too it is somewhat
unbelievable but it is real and it's one
of those things like hypnotism is real
but people don't think it's real and no
matter how much convincing you try to do
whatever but I always say like if this
wasn't real if Perry was an actor
he would be the greatest actor you if
you've ever seen because I mean yes you
can't portray you can pretend that more
of an accomplishment if it wasn't real
and where is Perry today Perry as is uh
has a show on Twitch and uh people give
him money to eat things and do things
and um he's like it's like this project
has like the fans have taken it over you
know but when he fi when he found out
when did he find out that this was not a
movie after uh we the one thing he was
suspicious about is that the whole thing
took seven days to shoot and he'd been
an extra on many films so uh the idea
that a movie took seven days did not
make sense to him and what we told him
we would just kind of play it as it goes
we told him well we ran out of money and
now Comedy Central wants to pick it up
and they want to make it into a prank
show and then mole one of the other guy
says I want to be the star I want to be
the guy the pranks are on and Barry
chimed in and said I will be the star I
will be the guy the pranks are on
all right Perry You're the star
[Music]